the killing of Abu Bakr al-baghdadi has
removed a figurehead from the top of
Islamic state but this decision to lower
the terror threat level was taken before
the killing the wider picture is that
Islamic state has lost its territory
most of its foreign fighters and much of
its ability to launch or inspire attacks
in Britain the group remains a threat as
does al Qaeda but not in the way that it
was for the general public I don't think
it'll make a significant difference they
really won't see much change but at
least it means that the situation is
reasonably under control the challenge
is of course that it doesn't stop the
lone individual from being radicalized
and choosing to go out and launch an
attack the decision was taken by Jatin
the Joint Terrorism analysis center an
independent apolitical cross Whitehall
body they review the latest intelligence
and meet formally twice a year although
can do so at short notice if needed to
jtac doesn't answer to Downing Street
this is not conveniently connected to
the upcoming election but the Home
Secretary announced the decision and
released this statement substantial
continues to indicate a high level of
threat and an attack might well occur
without further warning Priti Patel said
the threat level is kept under constant
review 2017 was a year of terror in
Britain it started here on westminster
bridge then there was the bombing in
Manchester and further attacks on London
Bridge at Finsbury Park and at Parsons
green the threat level was briefly
raised to the highest level critical
meaning that an attack was imminent has
come down since twice now but London in
particular remains a changed city's the
barriers along the bridges are testament
to that dreadful year
practically nothing will change now that
has been downgraded to substantial there
are still 800 ongoing terror
investigations and mi5 and
counter-terror police will continue to
work on those with the same tempo and
attention it is good news of course that
the threat level is lower but it still
means that an attack is likely and it
still means that there are many
dangerous people out there who want to
harm Britain Allister uncle's coinies